each and every year a debate erupts on
the interwebs
is die hard a christmas movie i say no
other years i say yes i'm complicated
just like this question so why don't we
get an answer
straight from the man himself john
mcclane
you got any christmas music now when it
comes to this long time pop culture
debate
here's what we know christmas is the
backdrop to die hard's story
absolutely it's a christmas movie it
takes place at christmas
it's an office christmas party it's not
setting the tree up but there are
christmas decorations everywhere
nakatomi tower there's a tree in that
whole movie and throughout the film
characters reference christmas and sing
holiday songs
non-stop oh the weather outside
is frightful it was the night before
christmas
this christmas theo it's the time of
miracles yeah and doesn't he say one of
his catch phrases is some sort of
you know ho ho now i have a
[Music]
but everyone has to admit die hard's
marathon of violence clashes with the
holiday's
overall aesthetic you wouldn't watch it
to get all the snuggly feel good to
christmas
i call it a christmas movie yeah is
there what's the argument against that
i guess the gunfire
that's a legitimate point but i still
think it means it's a christmas
movie adding more fuel to the fire 20th
century studios dropped a
christmas-style
trailer in 2018 to celebrate die hard's
30th anniversary
he just wants to spend christmas with
the family
together in the greatest christmas story
ever told
but there's one person who should have
the final word on the matter
i did this rose for one reason and for
one reason only
to settle something once and for all
bruce making this declaration at the end
of his comedy central roast in 2018.
die hard is not
a christmas movie
it's a goddamn bruce willis movie
this is their idea of christmas i gotta
be here for new years